[Music]
it's an eight-legged hair-raising
predator and the largest spider in the
world
the Goliath tarantula a full-sized adult
has a leg span up to a foot long a
powerful hunter it can kill creatures
bigger than itself it's razor-sharp
fangs measure an inch long and drip with
venom barbed hairs can fire into the air
and strike the eyes skin and throat
under the cover of darkness it waits and
works then strikes when least expected
if a tarantula lands on you what should
you do should you smash it with your
hand roll around on the ground or do
nothing the correct answer is C doing
nothing if you try to smash it the
tarantula will defend itself with its
nasty though non-lethal bite rolling on
the ground in a panic will likely hurt
you as much as the spider but if you do
nothing the tarantula who thinks you're
just a big moving land mass will
eventually walk off to find more stable
and safer ground and that's how you
survive an encounter with a tarantula
you